you know i'm not gonna lie to you i had
jokes for the beginning it's like oh
it's a movie called the northmen played
by the guy who played eric northman in
true blood true blood tie-in jokes after
watching this movie all i could say here
is holy
[Music]
had to edit that out youtube does not
like f-bombs dropped in the first minute
it'll get you demonetized the way it is
also thank you for clicking on my face i
love you for that last video someone in
the comment section was like he didn't
thank me for clicking on his face oh but
i do appreciate you for clicking on my
face we're coming up on me doing this
for 13 years now 13 years this summer
you're still clicking on my face i
cannot illustrate how much i appreciate
that and appreciate you for that so
thank you on to the northmen the
northmen is a robert eggers directed
revenge epic set in the year 900
something viking territory you know
norse times it stars alexander skarsgard
who's on this war path this revenge path
against his uncle who killed his king
father he's basically lion king but you
know norse times norse mythology which i
hear this movie is based off of the
legend that inspired hamlet which
inspired lion king so you know it's all
connected wait this is the one minute
mark for this video so i gotta say holy
[ __ ] this movie had to be said because
it had to be said but we got revenge
blood brutality betrayal of family all
the things we love to see in cinema keep
us warm at night i gotta say man this
movie was epic
i
i was just an enthrall i was surprised
at how much i loved being in this world
there were things i didn't expect in
this movie i expected you know like the
viking guy on his revenge quest i didn't
expect as much mysticism in the movie as
i got there's actually a lot of
mysticism magic mythology all in the
spectrum of norse mythology of course
now everyone in this movie is great
though they're not the most relatable
crew but they're not supposed to be so
one of the things i liked about this
movie is this movie builds a world of
900 a.d viking territory viking times
this movie doesn't build a world that
speaks to our egocentric sense of 2022
civility no it speaks to the audience on
a much deeper visceral
sense of primal rage that is to say the
film is brutal not just in violence but
when violence does go down it is brutal
but it's the overall sense of the world
that's the brutal part that's the part i
appreciate it's a world where if you
look at it through our modern day
goggles there are no good guys but to
the times they come from they are good
guys and as much as i have no doubt even
the brutality of this world and the
characters in it heroes villains alike
are the nerfed or otherwise pretty depth
more palatable versions of them i
appreciate the effort that went into
accurately depicting the brutality of
the times and the people in it and now
i'm in my head going what is brutality
what is civility i'm sure in the year 3
100 some gritty filmmakers gonna make a
movie that takes place in 2022 sure the
people in that time will be like did you
see the people of 2022 in that new movie
savagery thus is the ever-flowing river
of the zeitgeist now this is a film
where the world is the enthralling
captivating element of it more than the
characters are i mean you're totally
down for alexander skarsgard and his
revenge quest but he is i mean dude's a
brute dude is a big hulking brute of a
human someone who was forged in the
fires of war and bloodshed comforted by
dreams of revenge for years i mean just
who he is not a relatably warm and fuzzy
human being but it's kind of what makes
the film awesome and it is in line with
the fact it's like no the movie doesn't
pretty itself up how weird would that be
it's like the super brutal world and
alexander skarsgard's uh he plays a poet
out for revenge though his poetry is his
sword his ink is blood this did have a
bit of a count of monte cristo element
in there too it had some of the flavor
of monte cristo i'm not talking the
movie the movie's a great swashbuckling
adventure and i love it but i'm talking
about the book the book is a much darker
revenge tale where it's like i don't
want to just kill these people i want to
[ __ ] with them and really wreck their
world that's in here and i enjoy seeing
that i would hope if i was on a revenge
quest i would have the patience to do
that been talking about the world but
what can i say the world was very
enthralling to me but everyone in the
movie did a great job anya taylor joy
once again is perfection also you see
people in this movie that have been in
other robert eggers films
it took me it took me much longer than i
want to admit to be like
who oh my god they're swollen to foe but
you got nicole kidman in the film too it
just it kind of shows that robert eggers
is becoming one of those directors like
nolan or scorsese were actors like oh
robert eggers making another movie i
really want to be a part of it please
another thing that makes me love this
world is how beautifully shot it is even
when dealing with death not just human
death like there's this the place that
they're in is just kind of a wasteland
there's some greenery there i wouldn't
want to live there but the landscapes
the volcano it all just looked gorgeous
and it translates to the fights too now
when i talk about the fights the battles
don't expect this movie just to be like
battle after battle yeah it's just
it's not an action movie but that
meticulous kind of craftsmanship you see
in every other facet of this film does
translate to the fights so when
fighting's happening there are very few
cuts it doesn't seem so jarring like you
see in a lot of movies these days like
directors are like no one knows how to
fight let's just hide it with edits that
doesn't happen in here there are long
stretches just like there are no cuts
happening it's just sword on sword steel
on steel bone on bone and the fighting
is so sparingly done that when it
happens it is special one fight one
conflict in particular i can only
describe it as it's like if anakin and
obi won if that fight was a lot shorter
but a lot more visceral a lot more real
a lot more testosterone and it was
translated from a souls game that's what
it felt like i've heard that there's a
lot of down time in the film i never
felt it i never felt the downtime it
never bored me because the down time was
still plotting scheming it was all in
the vein and spectrum of revenge so for
me the film was always moving forward at
a very healthy pace in the end the
northmen it worked for me on
i can't think of a thing in this movie
that i would change this movie's not
going to be for everybody absolutely 150
percent there are people who would be
like oh it dragged on in parts i have i
get it but there are people out there
who don't like jrpgs like old school
snes jrpgs but if they got their hooks
into you
you live for them that's what this
movie's like it's like an old-school
jrpg it's like you either love it or
it's not your thing but if you love it
you're in for an experience that's what
this movie is i i would say it's one of
my favorite movies of the year but it's
really one of my favorite experiences of
the year and i have no question in my
mind the northman is
awesome tacular
[Music]
that'll be in your head too i will
avenge you father i will save your
mother i will kill you filner that'll be
your lullaby the night after you watch
this film all right so the northmen have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what's your favorite revenge tale
doesn't have to be a movie it could be a
book but what is it i love a good
revenge tale so whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you